[تصفيق]
مليون حاله اكتئاب حول العالم
سبعه فاصله مليون طفل ومراهق بحاجه لدعم
نفسي
انعمل احصائيه
ل 5000 لاجئ سوري
وبالنتيجه 33%
منهم
عندهم اكتئاب وامراض نفسيه بحاجه لدعم
في امراه
عمرها 29 سنه
عاشت مع الاكتئاب اكثر من ما عاشت بلاغ
بلش لما كان عمره 14 سنه
يعني طفله
حست بوقتها لاول مره بالعجز
تعبت كتير
نامت كتير
ما عاد تفاعلت
استمر لوقت
وبعدين راح ما بتذكر كيف
بعد بسنه
رجعوا الاعراض
ورجعوا بقوه
كانت بوقتها صف تاسع
حسيت انه خلصت الدنيا وما بدها تقدم الفحص
قالت لامها لانك اول وحده ولا اخر وحده
بعدين
قبل الفحص بيومين
قالت لامها مشان خاطري خلينا نجرب
بالفعل نفدت
من وقتها لهلا
خمس 14 مره صار معها
سنه واحده بس ما اجا
14 مره
خسرت كتير
خسرت دراستها شغلها شغفا صحتها
كان يراود افكار انتحاريه
كل مره
بس كانت تخاف على اهلها من الصدمه
14 مره ما استسلمت
ايام المدرسه
تعرضت للتنمر
مره وهي مكتئبه قلدوه
انها مثل القرده
وبعدين
اتهموها بالانطوائيه
وبالضعف وبالمياعه
بقله الذوق وبانها عم تفرح عم تخرب فرح
عيلتها
ورفقاتها زعلوا منه
كان يحس فيها
راحت عند خمس اطباء
محلله ومعالجه ومعالج كلهن نفسيين
تركستين الاكساسير
سبع انواع ادويه اخذت ولسه عم تاخذ
والدواء اللي عم تاخدو هلا يمكن يخف
مفعوله وتاخد دواء جديد
بس مرض خيط للمرض
ببدايته
ببلش ينخطف ينخفض المزاج
بتبلش تقاوم تقاوم تقاوم
بعدين بصير في تردد تردد كتير
مع اول رنه التلفون ما بترد عليها بتعرف
انه اجا
اذا خطرت تجرب تطلع مع رفقاتها لتغير جو
بتوصل على الباب
وبعدين بتحس انه لا ما بدي روح ما فيني
اطلع
ببلشوا الافكار السلبيه ينهشوا بالراس
ينهشوا ايه
لتحس انه بدك تشيل راسك لانه انفصل عن
جسمك
الاكتئاب مانو حزن عابر ولا نحزن مستدين
اكتئاب اثقل من هيك
تشتهي تنام كل الوقت وما تفيق
وصعب تنام
كانت لما تخاف
علمتها اختها صغيره
يلي هي
لا لا لا لا لا لا
لا
لا لا
[موسيقى]
لا لا لا لا لا
كانوا يرددوها هنن تنتين مع بعض مشان بس
يخفوا التوتر والخوف وترجع تحس باللحظه
بتتخيلوا مره كان عيد ميلادها
اهلا بدهم يساعدوها حبوا يفاجئوها
عزموها قرايبينا القراب كتير واللي
بيعرفوا حالتها ورفيقتها
واضطرت تفوت تتحمم
بقلب الحمام ما قدرت تساعد حاله
اجت اخطر الصغيره حممتها
وهي بلشت تبكي نشفت لها شعرها ضليت عم
تبكي عم تبكي بشكل هستيري لبست ثيابها
وضلت عم تبكي عم تبكي ما انا قادره تطلع
هالخمس دقايق
وتطفي الشمعه
تبتسم وترجع لغرفتها لعزلته
وما طلعت
بس كل مره كل مره
كانت تطيب مع الادويه
وكانت ترجع لقوتها
وترجع تقدر الصحه
وقيمه الحياه ونعمه الشعور
هي بتخاف من الاكتئاب
وبتشوفه بمناماتها بس ما بتخجل منه
ايه ما بخجل منه
[تصفيق]
بحكي
بحكي من اول مره حكيت قالوا لي لا تحكي بس
حكيت
لانه بعرف انه الاكتئاب واعراضه ما
بتشبهني
بس باوقات كنت اشعر اني ضحيه
باوقات كنت اسال حالي ليش انا ولقيمتها
غير انه الاكتئاب مرض بينكوس شو يعني
بينكوس يعني اذا صار مره وما تعالج
راح يصير مره تانيه واذا صار مرتين وما
تعالج احتماليه الثالثه كثير كبيره
فكيف مع 14 مره
بس انا قرات وبحثت عن الموضوع
واجهت حالي
واستكشفت ماضيه
وصلت انه الاكتئاب هو نتيجه
والاسباب معرفه ضروريه
مشان العلاج والوقايه
الاكتئاب انتشاره مخيف
ارقام مهوله
بسوريا ما في ارقام دقيقه
بس بعد الحرب
والظروف الحياتيه الصعبه اللي عم نعيشها
فالارقام عم تتزايد
في صبيه اسمها شمس كانت عايشه بسوريا وكان
عندها اكتئاب وكانت بتعرف
ببدايه الحرب سافرت مع عائلتها على
الجزائر
وعاشت سنتين قاسيين كتير
وبعدين انعمل لهم شمل وراحت على امريكا
امريكا الحلم
بس
الاكتئاب ما تركه
هي كانت بتعرف انه الحل الوحيد انه تروح
عن طبيب او معالج وتتعالج بس كان خايفه
كيف بدها تتواصل معهم
كيف بدها تشرح انه هاي البنت الصبيه
الامراه
يلي صارت مهندسه ميكانيك يلي بتجيب مصاري
كتير وانكليزي ممتازه هي نفس الطفله يلي
كانت تمشي حافيه بمنطقه ركن الدين بالشام
بس مع هيك
راحت عن طبيب وبلشت تتعالج وعم تتحسن
وفي شاب اسمه لؤي شغيل ناجح
بلش يشعر بوجع بالمعده
راح عن دكاتره
وعملوا لها تحاليل وعلى طول النتيجه سليم
بعدين حولوه عن طبيب نفسي
وشخص له اكتئاب حاد عم يتجلى بالجهاز
الهضمي
فالاكتئاب
بيختلف من شخص لشخص من حاله لحاله
والمريض النفسي
اللي عنده مرض نفسي
بحاجه لدعم من يلي حواليه
والاحتواء
وللصقه
بالاضافه انه المريض النفسي باماكن العمل
مثل اي موظف عادي
اذا مرض
الموظف
قرب فهو راح يغيب راح ياخد اجازه ليرتاح
ويطيب
كمان اللي عنده مرض نفسي بس يتعب بيحتاج
يغيب
ويرتاح
من دون ما يعتبر غيابه تقصير بالشغل او
استهزاء
وانت
اذا كنت عم تعاني من وجع الاكتئاب فيك
تحكي في مين بيسمع
دور على اللي بيحبك وبس
دور على طبيب مختص
ترتاح له بركي بخف وجعك
احضن حالك مشانك
وغامر كرمالك
ولا تخجل
لانه مرضك النفسي مانو انت
شكرا
[تصفيق]